pêche aux canards combats de chevaliers
chamboule-tout stand de maquillage les
animations étaient nombreuses ce week
end au château de la madeleine objectif
réunir des fonds pour l'association
vaincre la mucoviscidose
la mucoviscidose maladie génétique la
plus importante en france il ya 2500
malades à peu près mais comme c contient
que vous allez dire à l'état ne donne
pas beaucoup la scion la grandeur et
bouteilles de vaincre la mucoviscidose
c'est d'avoir monté au niveau régional
pour les malades ce qu'on appelle des
crcm de descente de soins spécifiques où
il ya les médecins spécifiques donc
quand un gosse est atteint comme lui qu
il va directement s'il veut là on est
venus pour soutenir la cause d'une part
et puis profiter du beau temps et puis
on connaît le château de la madeleine
donc l'année dernière c'était sympa mais
faisait un temps abominable et là ça
s'est vraiment étoffé donc c'est très
bien très plaisant et c'est important
oui bien sûr comme
comme en plus on connaît des gens qui
sont touchés c'est ça nous touche aussi
et puis c'est à côté chez nous et puis
fait bon et puis c'est facile de venir
soutenir mouvement passer une bonne
après-midi chaque année fin septembre
400 virades de l'espoir sont organisées
à travers la france en 2011 les
différentes manifestations organisées
par le collectif de chevreuse saint rémy
ont permis de récolter 80 mille euros
pour financer la recherche et apporter
une aide médicale et financière aux
malades